aquí tenemos varios triángulos y
queremos determinar si algunos de ellos
son semejantes y para eso vamos a
utilizar los criterios de semejanza que
ya vimos vamos a empezar con este
ejemplo de aquí aquí tenemos el
triángulo ac y el triángulo bsd y
observa que estos dos triángulos
comparten el ángulo en sí además de esto
tenemos marcado que es paralela a bd y
por esta razón los ángulos
correspondientes por esta transversal
son iguales es decir este ángulo de acá
es congruente a este ángulo de acá y con
esto terminamos esto nos permite
concluir que el ac y dbc son triángulos
semejantes utilizando el criterio ángulo
ángulo este ángulo es congruente a este
y este ángulo pues es 'urgente' asimismo
vale entonces déjame apuntarlo por aquí
arriba tenemos que el triángulo el
triángulo
e
es semejante a y aquí hay que ser
cuidadosos tenemos que ir en el orden
correcto verdad de naranja a azul a nada
entonces vamos de naranja al triángulo
de azul c a nada de esto es por el
criterio ángulo ángulo ángulo ángulo muy
bien vamos a este segundo ejemplo este
se parece un poco al de la izquierda
otra vez tenemos dos triángulos con un
ángulo en común aquí arriba pero ahora
no sabemos si esta recta es paralela a
ésta parece que no lo son pero aunque
parecieran no hay que dejarnos guiarnos
nada más por nuestra vista tendría que
estar marcado que son paralelas para de
adeveras poder usar eso vale bueno
entonces no podemos suponer que son
paralelas sin embargo tenemos
información acerca de los lados
a lo mejor eso puede ayudar vamos a ver
si las razones correspondientes entre
las parejas de lados son las mismas vale
entonces déjame déjame tomar el color
naranja para marcar este lado de acá
entonces vamos a intentar verificar si x
xy entre y aquí hay que ser cuidadosos o
sea que es lo que podría resultar este
es el lado chiquito del triángulo
pequeño entonces éste tendría que
corresponderse con el lado chiquito del
triángulo grande eso lo que nos motiva a
hacer es comparar x y con x con este
grande de acá vale entonces la razón que
vamos a hacer es xy entre xt y nos vamos
a preguntar si esa razón es la misma que
voy a tomar otro color rojo está bien xz
xz ahora es el lado grande del triángulo
pequeño comparado o bueno dividido entre
el lado grande del triángulo grande
entonces sería dividido entre x s x s
pues vamos a hacer las cuentas a ver qué
pasa x ya tenemos que es 2 entonces esto
sería 2 y existe existe tenemos que es 3
+ 1 entonces esto sería 4 y queremos ver
si dos cuartos es lo mismo es lo mismo
que x z o sea 3
/ / x s y x s es 24 o sea de 6 entonces
queremos ver si 2 cuartos es igual a 3
sextos y si estas dos fracciones son
iguales las dos son iguales a un medio y
por lo tanto aquí podemos utilizar el
criterio del criterio lado ángulo lado
entonces déjame poner que los triángulos
son semejantes que el triángulo y aquí
hay que ser particularmente cuidadosos
porque como que volteamos los lados va
entonces el triángulo de x zeta
x z es semejante semejante al haber fui
de y por el lado pequeño hasta x
entonces vamos de t hasta x al triángulo
de x s t x s vale y ahora estoy aquí es
por el criterio por el criterio lado
ángulo lado los lados no tienen que ser
congruentes simplemente deben de estar
en la misma proporción vale bueno vamos
al tercer ejemplo es esta figura de acá
tenemos un ángulo recto y tenemos una
línea que va a este punto b pero no
nada acerca de esta línea parece ser que
aquí es perpendicular pero si no está
marcado no podemos suponer lo entonces
vamos a ver si podemos encontrar
triángulos semejantes a ver el bdc y el
cda pues tiene en este lado en común
tienen este ángulo en común pero no
tenemos mucho más verdad a ver qué tal
el verde con el verde con el de hace
pues también tenemos este ángulo en
común este lado en común pero no mucho
más y estos dos triángulos pequeños de
aquí tienen este lado en común pero pues
no sabemos nada en realidad tenemos muy
poquita información y entonces aquí no
podemos determinar nada acerca de los de
semejanzas vale si aquí tuviéramos un
ángulo recto las cosas serían un poco
más interesantes porque ahora sí
compartirían el pequeño y el grandote
compartiría en este ángulo y este de acá
pero bueno no lo tenemos así que aquí no
podemos determinar nada vale bueno ahora
vamos a este ejemplo de aquí en este
ejemplo de aquí tenemos las longitudes
de los lados de los triángulos y ahora
si los triángulos están separados
entonces pues lo más razonable sería
pues
si están en la misma proporción cada una
de las parejas de lados correspondientes
vale a ver las parejas de lados
correspondientes tendrían que ser pues
vamos por tamaños aquí en el lado más
pequeño mide 3 y acá es el de 9 raíz de
3 entonces ésta tendría que
corresponderse con esta ahorita vemos
qué pasa va luego el siguiente el
mediano es este de aquí y tendría que ir
con este de acá y finalmente finalmente
déjame agarrar el color rojo este de
aquí tendría que corresponderse con este
de acá entonces vamos a ver si las
razones si quedan vamos a ver si 33
entre 9 raíz de 3 entre 9 raíz de 3 es
igual a 3 raíz de 3 3 raíz de 3 entre
entre 27 y también hay que ver si eso es
igual a 10 es igual a 66 entre 18 raíz
de 3 bueno vamos a hacer las cuentas
aquí este 3 se cancela con este 9 nos
queda 1 entre 3 raíz de tres en el de
aquí en medio el 3 se puede cancelar con
el 27 nos queda raíz de 3 entre 9 esto
parece distinto pero ahorita lo vemos
con más calma y finalmente este 6 con
este 18 se cancela aquí se hace un 1 y
aquí abajo nos queda 3 raíz de 3
entonces el primero y el último son
iguales nos queda 1 entre 3 raíz de 3
eso está bien el primero con el último
pero el de medio se ve un poco más
sospechoso verdad aquí tenemos 1 entre 3
raíz de 3 y aquí aquí tenemos raíz de 3
entre 9 bueno vamos a racionalizar esto
de aquí porque a lo mejor racionalizando
lo vemos que es igual esto de acá
entonces esta expresión es uno entre
tres raíz de tres para racionalizar
multiplicamos por raíz de tres arriba y
abajo
raíz de 3 arriba nos queda a raíz de 3
esto simplemente es un 1 entonces la
expresión no se altera y abajo nos queda
3 por raíz de 3 por raíz de 3 raíz de 3
por raíz de 3 33 por 39 entonces nos
queda la raíz de tres entre 9 y eso está
muy padre porque eso es justo justo lo
que estaba en la expresión de aquí en
medio entonces estas tres razones son la
misma y por lo tanto estos dos
triángulos estos dos triángulos son
semejantes vamos a ver si cabe por aquí
el triángulo el triángulo
efe
efe es semejante con triángulos
semejantes es semejante al triángulo a
ver hay que ser cuidadosos él
es el opuesto al naranja entonces aquí
tiene que ser h al triángulo h h luego
va el g que es el opuesto al azul
entonces tiene que seguir jota y bueno
la tercera letra tiene que ser que vale
entonces vamos a ver si es rojo vamos
avanzando de aje o sea rojo naranja
naranja azul y aquí también tiene que
ser en que se rojo naranja azul muy bien
entonces estos dos triángulos son
semejantes por el criterio el l el que
simplemente pide que sean proporcionales
va y bueno para terminar vamos con estos
triángulos de aquí estos triángulos pues
son como medio truculentos porque ve
comparten un ángulo este ángulo es igual
este de acá y además parece ser que
tienen la misma proporción porque para
pasar de 4 a 8 multiplicamos por 2 y
para pasar de cinco a diez también
multiplicamos por dos sin embargo hay
que ser muy cuidadosos porque aquí aquí
tenemos que los lados
nos dan son los correspondientes al
ángulo que nos dan pero aquí tenemos que
el ángulo está por otro lado entonces en
realidad este lado no es correspondiente
a este de acá sino tal vez a este de acá
y este no es correspondiente este de acá
vale sino correspondiente a este de acá
es el opuesto a este de acá entonces
bueno o sea así parece que son
semejantes pero es una ilusión óptica en
realidad no lo son porque porque no
tenemos los lados correspondientes
correspondientes proporcionales y
entonces no podemos utilizar lado a
ángulo lado sería otra historia si
tuviéramos el 5 porque entonces ahora sí
tendríamos los dos lados proporcionales
alrededor del ángulo correspondiente
pero como no lo tenemos no podemos decir
nada interesante acerca de la semejanza